I'll show breasts bodies paper you ready
to party yes I'm ready to party why do
you think I'm wearing this we're playing
crypt of the necrodancer so this is the
crypt of the necrodancer it's a rhythm
based game so you have to walk in attack
and do all this cash [ __ ] in the beat of
the bed the Pieta what what let's go
I never I only played the tutorial so
I'm probably gonna suck can you feel the
beat oh yes yes Oh Camille my twin is in
the air to wait for life we don't care
oh [ __ ] I should be a [ __ ] songwriter
that's [ __ ]
oh my god I'm so [ __ ] so when the floor
is this dis going like I just failed ah
that means oh my god it's so hard it's
hot
I will
okay the floor dancing that means that
we're doing good
okay Camaro Camaro
before marriage just gotta keep moving
to the rhythm of the beat I'm sorry oh
my god he sings
this is the greatest game of all time
but in sweetest music in this game oh my
[ __ ] god rhythm of the beat oh oh oh
so then scale it to oh my god is that a
[ __ ] dragon oh what the
hahahaha let's try that again every
single enemy in the game has a different
move set and you have to kind of move
according to their move set to not die
get the beat go with in my [ __ ] feet
[ __ ] one two three or sock martinis on
the floor second potatoes girl oh oh oh
yeah game what's up sing for me man
well [ __ ] off then what do I do with a
[ __ ] dragon
[ __ ] off how do i ah oh I get it I
attack from the side everybody dragon
bridge oh oh yes oh yes can you feel it
as diggle huh can you really jiggle
[ __ ] yes you turn Oh sing for me Danny
said
do a little dance
right Oh
oh my [ __ ] on one side wonder how do
I supposed to know how the paper talking
back in yeah they don't know nothing's
up
hey always got the rhythm here and I
blow God what is that [ __ ] slender
language [ __ ] sliding around [ __ ]
keep the temper [ __ ] yes yes yes oh oh
oh oh oh I love it so much
oh oh oh oh fun Oh Teddy Teddy Teddy ass
yes [ __ ] haha doing [ __ ] amazing now
look at me a [ __ ] pro at this game
I'm about to go algebra never mind
anything I just said okay we need a
golden key oh my god we're civilized
somehow oh my god this is so intense
come on brats
oh my god Suns amazing okay what the
[ __ ] are you
there's like all the key
I'm fine yeah you're welcome
got quite welcome yeah where's the
native oh my god you're ugly permanent
upgrade see that's what I wanted
goddamnit
[ __ ] oh my god
not today
oh why is every enemy moving towards me
look at this don't worry sir I'm a fun
together kiss huh no problem
oh god what's that folks did I do down
there hmm what is this
I have have one life does not each name
good okay well this is [ __ ] Swedish
[ __ ]
well oh my god [ __ ] me in the [ __ ]
deck deck Hey
I fell down a hole it stopped recording
but here we go bro are you with me are
you with me
can you feel it the juice can we do
anything down here that's a negative
okay we go
oh [ __ ] me it's like the real chess
I gotta hits in there did we do it dad
was always coming and going on as it
French oh my god
but this time he seemed more excited he
said he'd found it some great treasure
when I was older I found the notes he
left behind I was intense
directions to a graveyard yeah we know
you anywho I tried to stop me but dad
had been gone for two years I had to
find him so there's a story to this game
I didn't I like I don't even know cool
game really love it you can have
constant music even hopefully breast
check this game out if you're interested
if you enjoyed this video now is a great
time to leave a like and I'll see you
the next one is always see I'll suppress
brother ramiz again my brother here on
the bed repeatedly inside and now the
widow will be proud and they came in
taken the kingdom indeed